...
-Liliane Glock,
vous avez été l'avocate
de Simone Weber,
la diabolique de Nancy,
du non moins célèbre routard
du crime, Francis Heaulme,
ou encore de celui que "Faites
entrer l'accusé" a finement baptisé
le coupable innocent,
Jacques Maire.
Comment avez-vous obtenu
ces dossiers ?
-Déjà, vous remarquerez
une chose,
ce sont des dossiers locaux
quand même.
Je suis un peu spécialisée
dans le criminel lorrain.
Bon. C'est gênant
de faire son autopromotion.
Si vous voulez, j'étais
parmi les quelques pénalistes
de l'endroit.
-Oui. La 1re rencontre
avec l'accusé est souvent
déterminante, dit-on. Elle guide
la relation qu'entretient
l'avocat à son client.
Est-ce que quelque chose se joue,
se dit ou se noue ? Paraît-il
que lors des 1ers contacts,
on n'évoque pas
les faits reprochés.
Est-ce que c'est vrai ?
-Déjà, il y a un grand saut
que personne d'autre
que l'avocat ne peut faire.
C'est qu'on passe quelque part
d'une image à une personne.
Pour ne pas dire d'un mythe
à une personne.
Simone Weber, c'était déjà un mythe
quand elle était en détention.
Et vous vous trouvez
face à une personne.
Humaine. Voilà.
Et ça, c'est déjà
un grand saut.
-Etes-vous du côté des avocats,
tel un Thierry Moser,
le conseil de la famille Villemin,
qui doivent être convaincus
de la sincérité du client
pour bien les défendre, ou du côté
de ceux comme André Buffard,
dont le job est de défendre
et pas de rechercher la vérité ?
Où vous situez-vous ?
-Je suis là
pour défendre mon client.
C'est peut-être un peu simpliste,
ça manque peut-être de subtilité,
mais je suis là pour ça.
-Donc vous n'êtes en aucune façon
de celles qui se désistent
si vous avez la certitude
que votre client ment ?
Ca n'a aucune importance ?
Vous êtes prête
à la défendre
à n'importe quel prix ?
-Déjà, 1re chose et ça me paraît
être un préalable indispensable,
c'est pas à n'importe quel prix.
Je ne lui demande pas la vérité.
Chaque fois que je le peux,
je regarde le dossier d'abord.
Et le client me dit des choses
qui sont soutenables ou non.
Et si ça n'est pas soutenable,
j'aurais même pas à dire à la
personne que je la défends pas.
-Liliane Glock, vous avez
la défense dans la peau.
Jusque parfois pousser
les choses très loin.
Je pense au rapport
de force avec les magistrats
que vous mettez en place et qui vire
parfois au Grand Guignol.
Faire comparaître l'un
de vos clients, Francis Heaulme,
dans le procès d'un autre
de vos clients, Jacques Maire,
c'était inhabituel.
-Bah oui et non.
Francis Heaulme, on le met
dans tout un tas d'affaires
qui l'ont pas concerné.
Vous ne le voyez pas,
c'est des pistes inabouties.
Mais quand même,
on le met en cause
et puis finalement, on lui fait
des excuses, je suis optimiste,
on lui dit, c'est fini, vous n'avez
rien à voir là-dedans.
Ce qu'on a fait
pour Francis Heaulme,
on peut le faire aussi
pour Jacques Maire. Vous voyez.
C'est intéressant de voir qu'on peut
inquiéter des gens qui de toute
évidence n'ont rien à y voir.
-Mais citer à comparaître
un homme
qui n'avait fondamentalement
rien à dire dans ce procès,
c'est pas n'importe quel détenu,
Francis Heaulme.
Il est célèbre et honni.
Son témoignage
était-il indispensable
ou y a-t-il quelque chose
de surjoué au fond ?
Votre confrère,
Hervé Temime, pense
qu'en tout avocat
sommeille un acteur.
Etes-vous d'accord ?
-Pas du tout.
En tout cas,
pas pour moi.
Si vous voulez,
on dit "les avocats",
les avocats,
c'est plusieurs métiers.
Chacun a son tempérament. Chacun
a sa façon de voir. Et au fond,
on n'est pas d'accord entre nous
et c'est bien ainsi.
Et moi, je ne suis pas du tout
sur cette ligne de défense
qui consiste à dire,
si je le dis bien, ça marchera.
C'est un peu ça, finalement.
-Vous ne
croyez pas
à la brillance du discours.
Qu'est-ce qui joue ?
-C'est pas la question d'y croire
ou de ne pas y croire,
je trouve que quelque part quand
même dans une société démocratique
au 21e siècle,
c'est dramatique qu'on ait que ça
pour défendre quelqu'un
qui est aux prises avec la justice.
Parce qu'en fait,
on a pratiquement que ça. On est
dans un système judiciaire
où l'avocat est mal vu,
où il a peu de pouvoir,
peu de possibilités,
et au fond, il n'a que des mots
pour défendre son client.
On viendra nous raconter que,
dans le temps de la procédure,
on peut demander
au juge d'instruction de désigner
un expert qu'on n'aura pas choisi,
sur une liste de l'accusation,
expertise à laquelle
on n'assistera pas.
Donc c'est vrai que la défense
en droit français,
ce sont les mots, d'accord.
Et si les mots ne sont pas lourds
de conviction et de sincérité,
à mon avis, ça ne marche pas.
Et j'ai entendu
Henri Leclerc dire,
je crois qu'il fait
une excellente synthèse,
il dit pas, il peut
m'arriver d'être cabotin,
il dit, quand je le dis,
je le crois,
à telle enseigne
qu'il faut même quelquefois
que mes confrères me disent,
attends, tu l'as vraiment cru ?
Et Leclerc de répondre : au moment
où je l'ai dit, oui, je l'ai cru.
-Vous dites
que la justice est biaisée,
la défense a peu de place.
Défendre l'indéfendable
est-il l'essence même
de votre métier, c'est donner corps
à votre serment ? C'est à la fois
un devoir et un honneur ?
-Ah oui, complètement. C'est
en effet un devoir et un honneur,
de défendre, mais on ne défend pas
que l'indéfendable,
entre guillemets,
parce que déjà,
c'est une expression
plus journalistique que juridique,
et qui n'est pas
forcément exacte.
-L'indéfendable dans l'esprit
de l'opinion publique.
-Dans l'esprit
de l'opinion publique,
si on compare des sociétés
différentes, des époques,
le curseur n'est pas
au même endroit.
Il y a eu des époques où quasiment
pour toute le monde,
le blasphème était
ce qu'il y avait de plus grave.
On a bien évolué depuis.
Donc,
l'indéfendable, déjà,
l'indéfendable, ça n'existe pas.
Et en plus,
notre profession défend
celui qui est seul aux prises...
En fait,
pour les affaires graves,
c'est même pas avec la justice
seulement, mais avec la société.
Et je crois que c'est une question
qui ne se pose pas en fait.
La vraie vérité, c'est que c'est
une question qui ne se pose pas.
Un avocat doit défendre
celui qui a commis même le pire
avec une limite, sauf
si vous ne vous sentez pas capable
de le faire, ça serait
au détriment du client.
C'est une clause de conscience.
Vous avez vous-même perdu un enfant,
on vous demande
de défendre un meurtrier d'enfant,
on peut pas exiger ça.
Mais autrement, c'est sûr que,
si personnellement, on n'est pas
spécialement impacté,
eh bah oui, il faut y aller.
C'est presque
un devoir civique.
-Il faut y aller.
Personne, le saviez-vous,
personne ne voulait plaider
pour Michel Fourniret.
Il a fallu
des avocats commis d'office
au contraire de Francis Heaulme,
sur lequel nombre d'avocats
louchaient.
Comment l'expliquez-vous ?
-On ne peut pas comparer.
Je le répète depuis des années
quand même maintenant. J'ai pas
plaidé toutes ses affaires,
mais un certain nombre,
de Francis Heaulme,
et j'espère, si c'est pas à moi
qu'on le doit, tant pis,
que, depuis le temps que j'en parle,
ça a quand même modifié
son image. Francis Heaulme
est majoritairement passé
pour un prédateur cynique,
pervers, qui jouit du malheur
et de la mort d'autrui,
mais c'est pas du tout ça.
Francis Heaulme, c'est...
en tant que personne
une production
de notre société, c'est pas
sa faute s'il est comme ça.
On va me dire, c'est facile.
Mais c'est aussi
un bon bouc émissaire.
Francis Heaulme, c'est un personnage
qui n'a pas la capacité
de se conduire normalement,
qui a été produit par une société
qui ne veut pas l'assumer.
C'est quand même ça.
Et condamner Francis Heaulme,
ça dédouane le reste de la société,
il faut pas s'y tromper.
Et Francis Heaulme,
c'est mon client,
j'aime pas employer
des mots péjoratifs,
mais à une époque où on y allait
quelquefois dans les expressions,
on aurait dit,
c'est un idiot de village.
C'est pas du tout
la même chose.
Je dois dire que, pour ma part,
je suis contente
de défendre Francis Heaulme.
-Que pensez-vous
de la fin programmée
des jurés populaires ?
-Quelle catastrophe !
Quelle catastrophe !
-Le droit de juger
appartient au peuple
et pas à l'école
de la magistrature ?
-Exactement. Exactement.
Quand vous vous dites que,
pour les cas les plus graves,
qui vont impacter toute la vie
de celui qui est accusé,
c'est quelqu'un qui a été reçu
à un concours de grande école.
Même si ces gens-là
sont éminents,
et il y a de très bons juges,
parce que, si on en a l'occasion,
je pense qu'on a un mauvais système
judiciaire au pénal
avec de temps en temps, souvent,
la proportion reste à déterminer,
un résultat qui est correct
parce qu'on a des bons juges.
On fait fonctionner
la justice
sur la qualité des juges
et non sur la qualité du système.
Donc je ne mets pas en cause
la qualité des juges,
mais je dis que,
au fond, en plus, c'est
une charge morale qu'on n'a pas
à leur imposer.
-Vous êtes viscéralement attachée
à l'oralité des débats.
Or les cours criminelles
départementales avec des magistrats
professionnels les remplacent.
-On en a déjà une expérience et
on reste dans l'oralité des débats.
Il faut voir une chose, pourquoi
on a fait ces cours criminelles ?
Parce qu'on n'arrive plus,
la justice est engorgée
jusqu'au niveau criminel,
c'est pas autre chose. Et on
n'arrive plus à purger les affaires.
On fait des cours criminelles
pour que ça aille plus vite.
-Dans une logique d'abattage.
-D'abattage,
en tout cas de purger
les dossiers qu'on n'arrive pas
à juger.
C'est ça, la réalité.
Et donc on va faire plus simple.
On met là-dessus de grandes raisons,
des juges professionnels,
c'est mieux, etc.
-Au départ, ces cours criminelles
étaient provisoires.
On devait faire un audit.
-C'était un essai, oui.
-Et ça dure.
-Il y en a une près de chez moi,
à Metz, et l'expérience
démontre, par exemple,
que les audiences
durent le même temps.
Une affaire
qui se jugeait en 3 jours
est toujours jugée
en 3 jours.
Il fallait entendre 2 experts,
on fait venir les 2 experts.
-Il y a pas un gain de temps.
-Non.
On gagne pas
de temps du tout.
Et je ne pense pas qu'il y ait
un bénéfice sérieux à procéder
de cette façon. Qu'est-ce
qu'on économise ? On économise
la... l'espèce d'intendance
qui consiste à établir
les listes de jurés,
à les vérifier, à voir ceux
qu'il faut enlever, etc.
C'est vrai que c'est une espèce
d'ingénierie qu'il faut...
Mais ça change rien, c'est pas ça,
le vrai problème.
Les audiences durent le même temps
et ça va pas mieux.
-Quel est l'écueil
de cette réforme,
à terme ?
-Le public va se désintéresser
de plus en plus de la justice.
Et ça, c'est pas une bonne chose.
Le public s'est déjà désintéressé
de la politique.
Comme le fonctionnement de la vie
politique est difficile à percevoir,
les gens disent, je retourne à
mes oignons, c'est-à-dire à ma vie.
Et je pense que la justice,
ça va être la même chose.
Et c'est quand même grave.
C'est grave, parce que
l'acte de juger,
c'est pas anodin.
Et que, pour qu'il y ait
une vraie légitimité,
déjà, il faut pas
une seule personne qui juge,
et il faut
une espèce d'échevinage
entre le public
et les juges.
Autrement,
la légitimité,
et pour les choses graves,
certes on n'a plus
la peine de mort,
mais une perpétuité incompressible
comme on dit,
c'est quand même
quelque chose.
Et pour que ça reste quelque chose
vraiment de légitime, d'honnête,
il faut que
le peuple participe,
que tout le monde participe.
En plus, notre cour d'assises
qui a des jurés,
elle a quand même
un autre défaut,
c'est que, à l'instar
de la vie politique d'ailleurs,
j'ai l'impression
qu'en France, on aime
les régimes présidentiels.
La cour d'assises est
un régime présidentiel.
Le président fait tout,
il accuse, il défend, etc.
L'avocat général, il pose
une ou deux questions, résiduelles.
L'avocat de la défense pareil
avant de parler à la fin,
mais on a déjà un président
qui est omniprésent.
On le sait
à travers les témoignages
plus ou moins officiels
de jurés
concernant le délibéré,
ce qui se passe un peu dans la salle
où on se réunit avec les jurés.
-Ce qui s'est passé
dans le procès de Simone Weber.
-Pour une fois,
parce que vous savez
que le secret du délibéré,
à la différence d'autres secrets,
est très sévèrement gardé.
C'est 1 an de prison,
15 000 euros d'amende,
et puis, des poursuites
qui existent. Bon.
C'est vrai que,
dans l'affaire Simone Weber,
c'est étonnant, l'affaire est
vieille, mais on s'en souvient,
Simone Weber est encore vivante,
il y a un ou une jurée...
-Qui avait témoigné
dans l'Est républicain en 2015.
-Exactement.
C'est une de vos consoeurs,
c'est donc sur la voie publique,
qui, particulièrement choqué
quand même, dit que,
se retirant dans la salle
à l'arrière de l'audience,
le président a mis la main
sur le dossier, a dit :
ça, ça vaut perpète.
-Donc il a orienté.
-Le président manifeste
son opinion
et en même temps, il témoigne
de son impérialisme
quelque part dans la cour
d'assises française.
Il est le seul
qu'on puisse pas enlever.
A la limite, il peut faire
l'audience à lui tout seul.
Et 6 semaines d'audience,
c'est rare quand même
pour une affaire criminelle
de droit commun,
qui n'est pas du terrorisme,
et plus l'audience est longue,
plus les jurés prennent du pouvoir.
Parce que la justice, c'est un lieu
de pouvoir, on le sait.
Et là, il y a eu 6 semaines
et ils ont pu contrebalancer
le pouvoir du président,
parce que cette jurée
ou ce juré dit
des choses positives.
Il dit, j'ai l'impression
d'avoir pu peser
pour qu'on soit justes.
Bah écoutez, si ça,
ça ne démontre pas
qu'il faut garder
les jurés d'assises,
c'est quand même
une belle démonstration.
-Vous parliez d'impérialisme,
d'autoritarisme,
Simone Weber s'est révélée
à son procès en diva
du fait divers, en reine
de la réplique, elle a transformé
le tribunal
en salle de spectacle.
Elle connaissait
sur le bout des doigts
les 18 000 pages
de son dossier d'instruction,
comment défend-on, Liliane Glock,
quand on a affaire à une cliente
qui mène elle-même les débats
et joue à guichets fermés ?
Comment on existe ?
-Déjà,
Simone Weber est quelqu'un
qui tenait ses avocats
en respect. Oui.
Et je crois
qu'il fallait faire la même chose
et c'est ce que j'ai fait.
C'est-à-dire...
-Lui tenir la dragée haute ?
-Quelque part, mais en acceptant...
-Et la laisse courte ?
-En acceptant le retour, voilà.
Notamment, par exemple, elle avait
pris l'habitude
de critiquer ses avocats
auprès du juge d'instruction,
éventuellement par écrit.
"Mon avocat Untel a fait ça,
c'est nul, je suis pas d'accord."
J'ai mis des bornes immédiatement.
Je lui ai dit, si vous voulez
me critiquer, vous me le dites
ou vous me dites
qu'on s'est vues assez longtemps,
mais j'accepte pas de voir au
dossier quand je vais le consulter
une lettre où vous vous plaignez
de moi. Je l'ai dit une fois.
Mais d'un autre côté aussi,
pareil, moi,
je respectais son caractère.
Et elle a récusé les jurés
elle-même. On n'avait jamais vu ça.
-Il y a quelque chose
de théâtral.
Elle a été victime plusieurs fois
de malaises. On se souvient d'elle
sortant sur une civière
de la cour d'appel de Nancy.
Y a-t-il aussi une part
de théâtralité aux assises
et dans ce procès en particulier ?
Sincèrement ?
Qu'en dites-vous ?
-S'il y a une part
de théâtralité,
c'est rarement l'accusé.
Dans ce procès,
on y vient.
Autrement, je dirais plutôt non de
la part de l'ensemble des accusés.
Maintenant, on a des procès
qui sont mâtinés de politique,
les procès de terrorisme,
c'est une autre histoire.
Mais le pénal traditionnel,
vous savez, l'accusé,
il est quand même
dans la cage en verre, hein.
Quant à Simone Weber,
c'est un cas un peu particulier.
-Elle est théâtrale.
-Mais oui, voilà.
Je veux dire,
quand on allait la voir
au parloir de la prison,
il y a pas de public là,
mais elle était la même.
J'avais pas le sentiment
de quelqu'un qui jouait
la comédie.
Elle était elle-même et c'était
peut-être pas d'ailleurs
une bonne idée d'être elle-même.
Après,
enfin, moi, je sais que
cette histoire de récuser les jurés,
j'étais à fond contre. Je lui ai
dit, si vous voulez le faire,
vous le faites, mais il faut pas,
c'est antipathique de récuser.
Et puisqu'on a parlé
de cette jurée
qui s'est exprimée,
elle a dit une chose
très intéressante
et qui me renvoie dans les cordes,
je crains pas de le dire,
elle dit,
à travers la récusation,
celui qui n'est pas récusé
a l'impression d'être choisi.
-C'est très juste.
-Et ce juré dit
ou laisse entendre, mais en tout cas
c'est ça le message,
j'ai senti que c'était elle qui
m'avait choisi et non pas l'avocat.
Bah j'avais peut-être tort,
c'est peut-être elle
qui avait raison.
-Liliane Glock, vous êtes aussi
l'avocate du Hamas.
Comment devient-on
l'avocate d'une organisation
terroriste, en tout cas,
telle que l'Union européenne
la définit.
-Et en plus, j'ai été
leur avocat sur ce sujet.
Il s'agit pas de conseil sulfureux
ou je ne sais quelle histoire,
ils sont inscrits sur la liste
terroriste européenne
et ils ont souhaité
à un moment donné en sortir,
demandé à en sortir.
-Ils en sont sortis
au Luxembourg.
-Très momentanément.
-Oui.
Enfin, pour un avocat,
c'est quand même
un plaisir si vous voulez,
parce que c'est
un tout petit séisme,
dans les conséquences,
mais c'est un tout petit séisme
momentané, mais planétaire.
Ca, c'est quand même la réalité.
Modestement.
-Comment devenez-vous
l'avocate des Palestiniens ?
Vous portiez
à un moment le keffieh.
-Simplement, j'ai eu pour client
un Palestinien de Nancy
pour une question
de titre de séjour.
Et ce Palestinien avait créé
une association pour collecter
quelques sous. De fil en aiguille,
je suis allé en Palestine.
Comment je suis devenue
l'avocat du Hamas ?
J'y étais
pour des raisons humanitaires,
on a demandé à me voir
en ce qui concerne
cette procédure à Luxembourg
devant une juridiction européenne.
Ces gens-là m'ont reçue,
c'était des chefs bien entendu
et ils m'ont donné une demi-heure
pour m'expliquer avec un traducteur.
Et ils ont décidé que oui,
on faisait la procédure.
J'étais un peu à la fois
surprise et émerveillée.
Et il s'agissait de quelque chose,
je vous dis, de très correct.
C'était... Enfin,
c'est une démarche positive
de leur part. On peut le dire
sans faire l'éloge de cette entité
comme dit l'Europe.
Mais ils demandent à sortir
de la liste. Ca veut dire
qu'ils s'en fichent pas.
C'est quelque chose de positif.
-Votre combat auprès d'eux
ne s'inscrit pas
dans une démarche
politique mâtinée
d'internationalisme, comme ça a pu
être le cas pour Jacques Vergès.
-Non, pas du tout. C'est rien de
politique. C'est vraiment juridique.
Je trouve justement aussi,
parce que,
quand vous faites partie
des entités terroristes,
c'est comme ça que ça figure,
la démarche qui consiste
à dire, oui, on le fait,
moi, j'étais épatée
qu'ils décident en une demi-heure
de confier leurs intérêts
à une blonde.
Oui, quand même.
Oui. Et après, d'ailleurs,
j'ai pu entretenir avec eux
de bons rapports. C'est des clients
qui me font confiance,
qui me demandent
sur les questions juridiques, etc.
C'est quand même
assez surprenant.
-J'aimerais revenir
sur Jacques Maire. Il a été condamné
en 1re instance, plus lourdement
condamné en appel,
avant d'être finalement acquitté
par la Cour de cassation
pour un vice de procédure.
C'est cela, la justice ?
Je le dis sans aucune ironie.
-Alors, en fait,
la Cour de cassation
ne l'a pas acquitté,
elle l'a renvoyé
devant une 3e cour d'assises.
C'est ça qui était un peu...
Il y a eu 3 audiences d'assises.
C'est pas toujours.
On a l'exemple de l'affaire
des enfants de Montigny,
où il y a eu une cascade
de cours d'assises.
Et il a donc été acquitté
par la cour d'assises de Metz.
Actuellement, et ces deux
affaires-là en sont quand même,
que ce soit Jacques Maire
ou les enfants de Montigny,
c'est des dossiers sur lesquels
on revient très tardivement.
Et la justice fait ce qu'elle peut
avec ce qu'elle a.
Avec des dossiers
où les scellés ont disparu.
Voilà, des choses comme ça.
Et... Bah oui,
c'est rendre la justice. Je vais pas
vous dire que ça me satisfait.
-Pourquoi ?
-Parce que, si vous voulez...
ma consoeur Dosé en parle
beaucoup mieux
que moi, parce qu'elle s'est
spécialisée sur cette question,
je suis pour le droit à l'oubli.
Il faut savoir rechercher la vérité,
il faut savoir faire un procès,
mais il faut aussi savoir
fermer la porte.
On ne peut pas éternellement
vivre dans la procédure.
C'est mauvais
pour tout le monde.
C'est mauvais pour les accusés
qui ont plus de mal à se défendre,
mais aussi pour les victimes.
Quel calvaire d'être victime
pendant des décennies !
C'est affreux quand on y pense.
-Les descendants
des victimes de Jacques Maire
demandent encore réparation.
Que dit-on à ces plaignantes qui ont
le sentiment que la justice
ne les entend pas ? Elles ont
le sentiment d'un déni de justice,
parce qu'il y a prescription.
-Avec ou sans prescription, parce
qu'on refasse un procès bancal
ou qu'on ne fasse pas
de procès du tout,
ce n'est pas la justice
qui les aidera à vivre.
-Et à faire le deuil ?
-Voilà.
Faire le deuil.
La justice, ça doit
justement permettre
de mettre un terme à un drame.
Quand la décision est rendue,
c'est fini. C'est pas là-dessus
que les victimes,
contrairement
à ce que certains pensent,
chacun a le droit d'avoir
son opinion et moi aussi,
je ne pense pas qu'on se reconstruit
à partir d'une décision de justice.
Ca vous permet justement
au contraire d'avancer,
de dire, ça, c'est fini,
c'est plus ma vie.
Et regarder toujours en arrière
vers une justice
qui n'a pas été parfaite, qui a été
peut-être insatisfaisante,
c'est se boucher l'avenir, mais
pratiquement jusqu'à votre mort.
A partir d'un moment,
il faut dire,
c'est fini, je n'aurai pas
de réponse. Il y a plein de domaines
dans lesquels on n'aura pas
de réponse. Il faut l'accepter.
Parce qu'autrement,
on entretient son malheur
et on n'en sortira jamais.
-Vous avez longtemps formé,
de fait, avec Francis Heaulme,
un vieux couple judiciaire,
c'est le client de votre vie ?
C'est le Joseph Vacher des temps
modernes ?
-Oui, mais, si vous voulez,
Francis Heaulme,
j'arrive à m'interpeller
moi-même. Le fait par exemple
qu'il continue à me téléphoner.
Simone Weber me téléphone
régulièrement
de manière espacée,
mais Francis Heaulme me téléphone
toutes les semaines.
-Qu'est-ce que vous incarnez
pour lui ?
-On m'a déjà posé la question,
mais à quoi ça tient ? Pourquoi ?
Je crois qu'en fait,
c'est le moment du procès où,
c'est court, hein,
mais vous êtes tout
pour votre client.
Si vous voulez, ce qui crée ce lien
que je n'arrive pas à définir,
parce que...
ça ne devient pas votre ami,
ça ne devient pas votre pote,
vous devenez pas
un membre de sa famille,
que ce soit pour Francis Heaulme
ou Simone Weber, c'est pas ça.
Et en cherchant, en réfléchissant,
moi, j'ai l'impression que c'est...
D'avoir vécu ensemble
un moment périlleux.
C'est ça. Si vous voulez,
le procès criminel,
entre l'accusé et son avocat,
on est sur un radeau.
Et... celui qui est
en meilleur état,
c'est l'avocat et qui peut
peut-être tirer l'autre de là.
Je crois que c'est ça qui fait
que Simone Weber continue
à me téléphoner, que Francis Heaulme
me considère comme proche,
sans savoir pourquoi finalement.
Ce qui les...
c'est pas mon talent.
Que j'ai ou que je n'ai pas.
Mon talent relatif.
C'est qu'ils ont
confiance en moi.
Ces gens-là ont vraiment
confiance en moi
pour n'importe quoi.
-Vous récusiez au début
de notre entretien
le mot d'indéfendable.
Diriez-vous néanmoins
que vous êtes l'avocate
de l'impossible ?
-Oui. L'avocate de l'impossible,
dans certains cas, certainement.
Parce qu'il y a des buts dont
on sait qu'on ne les atteindra pas.
Même si on a la conviction
que le client peut être innocent,
on sait que l'acquittement,
on ne l'aura pas.
Je savais que Francis Heaulme
ne serait pas
acquitté. C'est quoi,
défendre les gens ?
Il est... L'accusé est indéfendable
à quel niveau ?
Qu'est-ce que vous espérez ?
Je vais vous dire,
en ce qui concerne les personnes
qui ont reconnu les faits,
je trouve qu'on a une justice
criminelle qui est mauvaise.
-Pourquoi ?
-Parce que celui
qui reconnaît les faits,
et je vais certainement choquer
des gens parmi le public,
je considère que celui
qui reconnaît les faits,
on pourrait lui éviter
la cage en verre.
L'aveu n'est pas valorisé
comme il devrait l'être.
Et celui qui avoue,
au fond, n'y gagne rien.
Il va quand même
subir un procès d'assises
où on va lui dire,
vous reconnaissez les faits,
bah heureusement, c'est
la moindre des choses !
C'est quand même pas parce qu'il
reconnaît que l'ardoise est effacée.
C'est ça, les réflexions.
L'accusé, qu'il avoue ou non,
il a toujours tort.
Et je trouve
qu'on pourrait rémunérer
plus significativement
celui qui reconnaît les faits.
C'est le plaider coupable.
Si on avait cette possibilité,
mes clients avoueraient
8 fois sur 10,
parce qu'ils l'ont fait
et parce qu'ils seraient d'accord.
-Merci, Liliane Glock.
-Merci à vous aussi.
SOUS-TITRAGE :
RED BEE MEDIA
...